marie-france et retraités elle est
bénévole au sein d' hf prévention et
elle a participé à l'opération dépistage
du vih au sein de l'université de
versailles saint quentin avant le test
minutes les étudiants répondent à des
questions concernant notamment leurs
pratiques sexuelles des pistes 1 nous on
n'est pas les parents avec les parents
peut-être ils vont pas discuter de tout
ça avec des personnes comme nous ça ne
nous dérange pas et puis s'ils ont envie
de parler bien mou bien sur wii a aucun
problème
après le questionnaire est donc possible
de bénéficier d'un test gratuit une
minute pour savoir pour montrer aux gens
qu'il faut que tout le monde puisse le
que tous puissent faire ce test très
important
c'est très rapide non plus ça fait pas
mal puis bon c'est une bonne un bon
moyen d'éviter d'aller faire des prises
de sang
c'est la première fois qu'à chef
prévention organisent une opération de
dépistage rapide à l'université en
partenariat avec l'association
d'étudiants icare et ce n'est pas anodin
pour cent quand même un besoin des
étudiants de se faire dépister bas sur
leur lieu de vie étant donné que ils
n'ont pas toujours les moyens de se
déplacer faut prendre le train
attrape les rendez vous c'est que le
jeudi soir donc c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu problématique avec leur emploi
du temps c'est les étudiants qui sont
très au courant il ya des étudiants qui
ont proposé dépistage qui nous disent ah
bah non moi c'est fait je les fais ya
deux mois il ya pas de problème et puis
on croise aussi des étudiants qui nous
disent ah non moi je me protège pas je
vois pas à quoi ça sert
les étudiants c'est le coeur de cible
tout comme effectivement les populations
homosexuelles ou les situent les les
populations donc précaire aux migrants
effectivement les jeunes font partie des
priorités en tout cas des nouvelles
priorités donc
gouvernement et on se retrouve
effectivement avec des jeunes qui sont
inquiets de leur statut sérologique
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle de voir
qu'ils ont une prise de conscience sur
donc les risques sexuels
l'idée pour hachette prévention c'est
d'intervenir plus régulièrement à
l'université à raison d'une fois tous
les deux mois
l'association est également hébergé au
sein de l'institut de promotion de la
santé à trappes en une journée de
présence a lu vs qu 85 jeunes se sont
fait dépister tous négatifs